all right so Florence Pugh's latest
movie The Wonder is now on Netflix and
no wonder you click this because this
psychological drama is a heck of a weird
period piece but in this video we're
going to be breaking down the story
Explain the ending of course the fourth
wall breaks our reaction and review
along with touching on some of the
themes and messages cleverly tucked away
in Wonder now if you enjoy this video
then hit that like button as it helps
the channel and allows me to go one more
day without food hey I'm fast in here
and also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns Recaps and other videos like
this every day with that out of the way
a huge thank you for clicking this I'm
your host Jared now let's get into the
video
[Music]
all right so a quick setup of the plot
reveals Mrs Elizabeth Wright played by
Florence Pugh is a nurse from England
who has been called to a secluded Irish
Countryside in 1862 nearly a decade
after the Great Famine in doing so she
along with a nun have been hired by a
committee of Elders in a town to
investigate a unique situation if you
will a young girl named Anna who
seemingly hasn't had anything to eat for
nearly four months this Oddity some
might even say a miracle is at the
center of this film why hasn't she eaten
does she not have to eat is she a plant
and solely lives off of chlorophyll now
more like borophyll oh
right with the elders calling in a nurse
and a nun it is an interesting dynamic
between science and religion especially
one's beliefs what do you believe is
actually happening with this young girl
what story are you going to take to
heart now this whole idea of belief is
almost in everything in the Wonder it's
centered around it essentially hell even
the opening breaking the fourth wall
moment the narrator tells us this is a
movie to believe in the characters
stories with complete devotion we are
nothing without stories and we invite
you to believe in this one believe me
pun intended but I was instantly
confused by why they were showing the
behind the scenes workings of Film
Production with this ethereal music
however it instantly grabs you allowing
you to believe in what you want about
this everyone has a story I know a very
snooty um I went to film school oh look
at me feeling behind this but it
instantly tells the audience to believe
what you do because us seconds later
were right there smack dab immersed on a
ship setting with Florence Pugh's
character and the power of belief brings
her to the committee who believes that
Anna is a miracle people traveling long
distances to see her because they
believe in what Anna is and Anna
believes that she is atoning for
something much greater you get a belief
you get a belief everyone gets a belief
I'm gonna drop a bombshell on you though
but uh yeah Anna is a foolish though she
and her family claim that Anna has
flourished for roughly four months
without a single piece of food is
straight up poppycock it's revealed that
her mother when giving you know morning
and good night kisses essentially baby
birds food into Anna's mouth chews it up
and spits it right in though sneaky and
tough to see the belief of this miracle
child living off of only the Manna of
Heaven is straight up false this is only
realized when Elizabeth prevents and his
parents from any sort of contact with
her surprisingly cases like this are
drawn directly from historical events
Emma Donohue the best-selling author of
The Wonder from which this movie is
based on studied roughly 50 cases with a
majority of them relating back to the
religious practices of penance sure some
of them were looked at as heroines of
their time religious Miracles like
Anna's case here but I'm gonna chalk him
up as the first influencers of the
Medieval Times without subscribeth to
the fans only anyway the reason in doing
so again derives from belief Anna
believes if she prays 33 times a day you
know Jesus's basketball number and she
atones AKA fast that her late brother
will be released from hell for what he
has done making his way to heaven
earlier the family states that the
brother went away and died during the
war something Elizabeth again believed
but in reality he never actually left
instead fell ill after he and Anna were
married assumed that you know they had
the parents blessing Anna called it
double love and that's not actually a
good thing the love of a sister and a
wife so um believe me when I say this
but it's some pretty [ __ ] up Sweet
Home Alabama but Anna's parents don't
seem to care that now she is slowly
withering away because they believe
there's that word again that in the
process of losing a child her atonement
for her brother's sins will allow both
of them to enter Heaven she even goes as
far as saying that life is short but the
next life is eternity her children will
be in heaven believing in something that
isn't entirely there doesn't fall solely
on Anna but Elizabeth has stories of her
own earlier she mentions that she's
widowed hinted at her husband dying
during the war as well but before each
night she is seen taking some sort of
liquid hallucinogen showing off her tiny
baby boots and pricking her finger
drawing blood another fact or fiction
hint as it's later revealed she lost her
baby and then that caused the husband to
leave her nightly tradition is just
dealing with the Heartbreak and even a
way of still kind of feeling something
you know from the self-harm in a sense
she doesn't want to believe her reality
now at the end of things nurse Right
comes to the conclusion that Anna is
going to die she's tried everything even
shoving a feeding tube down her gullet
which I I'm gonna be honest was not a
pretty sight but instead persuades Anna
through a different narrative and the
power of belief that has you know been
the common thread or theme through this
movie Anna can save her brother while
also being reborn as a nine-year-old
before any of these horrible events from
her brother had happened the liquid
hallucinogen dopes up Anna taking her to
the holy well for an almost a baptism in
a sense nurse right watches over the
death of Anna and and then the rebirth
of her new identity non I guess you
could say
hey hey hey okay that was a bad joke but
I thought this name was actually a
shorter version of Anna but Nan actually
means Grace in Grace in Christianity
means a couple of different things the
spontaneous unmerited gift of the Divine
favor in the salvation of Sinners so
Anna giving herself for the Salvation of
her brother and that of the nature of
human depravity and regeneration so
through the perverted acts of her
brother Anna fasted and is now reborn as
a new spirit and finally that of the
relation between grace and Free Will
Anna or non now has the free will to
live her own life this is seen at the
very end when she's adopted by Elizabeth
and will both had lost their families
and instead now Start Anew Anna Begins
to eat at the end of her own free will
something that was different for from
you know the past four plus months that
she had been living before there is a
final bit of Storytelling and belief
themes when Elizabeth has to meet with
the committee about what happened with
Anna and the house burning down though
all of the evidence is very much against
Elizabeth with her being the one that
started the fire even though she claimed
that it was an accident and it's odd
that no remains at all no bones nothing
of Anna can be found the committee
believes her story pays her and allows
her to head back to England this is all
closure for Elizabeth though allowing
the past of her husband and child to
burn away and she like Nan is reborn
with this new life now with Will and Nan
sailing off to Sydney Australia to do
whatever you know Australians do let's
put another shrimp on the Bombay before
we wrap up we gotta talk about the
fourth wall breaks and the questionable
ending obviously the opening of this
movie is a behind the scenes look at
this movie The Raw set of it all with
the narrator urging us to believe the
story well the narrator is Neva algar
who is actually playing Anna's sister
Kitty and throughout the movie she mean
mugs the camera a couple of times even
reminding us that we are nothing without
stories Nana looks at the camera when
registering her name on the boat subtly
hinting that this is her story before
ending with the same turn to set break
the fourth wall bit with algar
whispering
[Music]
all right
this on the surface ties back to the
dhama trip Anna is given earlier of the
bird and the cage is the bird free or is
it trapped in out in out meaning Anna
was the bird heck she was even being fed
like a bird from her mother but this is
her story and she was able to get out of
this abusive manipulative religious
based situation that she was trapped in
with her family it's a miracle she is
now free but if we blow this symbolism
out to the real world which I believe
see what I did there Niva algar being
dressed in modern clothing shows us that
these stories are happening today in
many different Avenues to many different
people not necessarily just
religion-based scenarios and it's our
job to believe in their stories to allow
them to no longer be trapped the Wonder
really surprised me with the deeper
meaning here honestly from the get-go I
thought it was just a solely like
religion versus science
Ovid movie I know it's very stupid I I'm
an idiot but the way they slowly held
out this carrot and allowed us to follow
the story deciding on who we should side
with was done so well it's both a period
piece with a relevant message but also a
heck of a mystery picking up on all of
these slight details and those clever
fourth wall breaks I thought Florence
Pugh was fantastic and really hit on
those emotional beats of the story I
love her work and she killed it I mean
well she didn't she didn't kill the girl
she saved her but uh you know what I
mean anyway I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Wonder and if you two
grew up with parents baby birding food
into your mouth or or was that just me
and I'll let you know we're currently
running the competition right now giving
away three copies of House of Dragon
season one
on the 15th of December and all you have
to do to get a chance of winning this is
like this video make sure to subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
Down Below on the Wonder we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now so
if that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out our
other videos right over there are 18.99
breakdown video is insane you you've got
to watch the show and go check out the
breakdown but with that out of the way
thank you for your constant support I've
been Jared and I'll see you in the next
one
all right uh goodbye now